all
okay uh good morning um I apologize for
the delay we have a um we have a hearing
for 10 o'clock on House Bill
2024 and at 11
o'clock um we are looking to uh exec on
that bill um unless we have any other
changes you have before you the
amendment to um House Bill
2024 that outlines all of the um
revisions three or four revisions Do's
revision um adding the uh removing the
maintenance of the Continental
Boulevard um out of as another item and
the Salvage rail for offset Trail
construction on the
Conway
excuse me Mr chair are they hard I
didn't seem don't seem to have a hard
copy I did get look at the uh copy
emailed yesterday for some
reason okay thank
you uh be before we uh before we open up
our conversation I would like to uh
thank um thank our Our Guest today Wayne
McDonald sitting to my right um sitting
in as a substitute today and uh thank
you for being here and uh welcome to
public works as as everyone else in the
room
um John did you have a point oh no I'm
all set for now Mr chairman thank so we
have um we had pulled uh this amendment
together uh everyone should have it if
we have questions on it we'll discuss it
has the department had a chance to
review the amendment and is the
department
um okay with as it's been uh added to
House Bill
2024 should he step up yeah why don't
you why don't you come forward to the
and let's let's hear that because I my
intention is
we get through this
today good morning Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
David rodrig assistant commissioner for
the Department of
Transportation one point of of
clarification for the committee to to
consider is on page three line 10 the
portion that refers to Continental
Boulevard in uh the town of of marac the
word maintenance is is used and the
committee may want to consider as to
whether or not there could be ambiguity
in the term maintenance and may want to
consider reclassifying the road to a
class five Road or keeping it as as
written um that's the only point of
clarification I would I would
make so if if to understand is the
department suggesting that Continental
Boulevard to be reclassified as class
five or what what's what's the revision
that you
were yes that's what we would ask the
committee to
consider removing the word
maintenance replacing maintenance to
reclassify yes of Continental Boulevard
to a class five Highway in the town of
maramont to become a class
five how how would you how would
you I would you like it word yeah I'm
I'm I I was hoping that this would have
been taken care of before today so let's
let's hammer it out right now okay
so
ofers Street Yeah
well yeah other other than uh the line
nine and line 10 is the department in
agreement with with as it's represented
in um this amendment yes we are in
agreement
okay further questions of the uh yes
please R Sam noin thank you could you
tell me what that is
now what yes I believe it's a class two
Highway further
questions AB oh excuse me uh please
represent B and reclassifying this to a
class five Road
what what does that
actually that that entails changing the
the ownership of the road from a class
two State Highway that turnpikes um
maintains to a class five road that the
town of marac would would maintain and
to be clear the Department's okay with
the language as written we just
anticipate that that could create some
ambiguity in which maintenance
responsibles responsibilities being
transferred I would agree thank you
please representative Abbott yes I just
wanted to um get a feel for what the
ambiguity is is would it because of the
word maintenance
is yes it is and and the RSA defines
maintenance I believe when it comes to
the maintenance of a road when it comes
to the different classifications as all
inclusive but when we talk about our
operations we have maintenance
operations we have planning design
construction reconstruction and and so
forth so the depending on on how it's
looked that there can be some question
to what that definition is represent
pulner so my understanding is that this
is a class two Road the Department's
actually required to maintain it there's
no provision for not maintaining it like
there is for class six roads in the
municipalities is that is that correct
and I guess I'm anticipating there might
be an issue of
somebody hits a rod or a pothole who
wants to sue the department for not
maintaining it is
that is that something we need that this
is intended to address I
guess right if if if if this were to say
class five all of that would be very
very clear um in the
when when it says maintenance again I
would still read this and could still
make the the argument that it means all
of the the maintenance including future
reconstruction and so forth but I think
somebody else could take a contrary
argument to that and then we'd be
talking about the definition of the word
where class five is defined in statute
as all maintenance
responsibilities further questions of
the department
represent CL here okay thank you I just
want to be clear and and try to
especially explain to any colleagues
outside of this chamber if we pass this
the way you want it the town of marac
will will not only own Continental but
be responsible for the maintenance is
that correct that is correct okay thank
you which is which is actually the
intent I I'm I'm thinking this is
cleaner okay
um okay no further questions for the
commissioner
um represent boy do you want to discuss
this
item the thank you Mr chairman the I'm
sorry before I do represent Jack did you
a question for the
commission oh thank you so much okay go
right ahead sir so just a for a point of
discussion I
asked um Karen Davis to help me out
two years ago this was presented as an
ownership chance transfer without
delineating that it was a class five
roadway so my
concern
is does the change of does the change of
a class Road based on what we did what
this body approved two years ago with me
being the sole person in the
minority okay how is what how is what
this committee did two years ago
different from from changing the type of
roadway that it exactly is from a class
two and moving it to a class 5 because
I'm not I'm not convinced because the
language as defined under class five the
definition is all traveled highways
other than class six that the town or
city has the duty to to maintain
regularly has the duty that that to me
the way that it's written right now or
how it proposes to be written doesn't
it's just you're changing a
classification of a roadway it's not
transferring ownership of the roadway to
the town and I'm not going to bore folks
with being redundant for my previous
comments about how much the town doesn't
want the road I I will spare you the
details but I think it's what I'm
looking at is I'm looking at two
competing versions of language that this
committee voted on two years ago and
doing something completely different and
I'm not sure
exactly what you're trying to accomplish
in either case I'm going to be against
it but now I'm I'm even more confused
based on what the previous author of
this amendment who used to sit where you
sat Mr chairman and I absolutely respect
the expertise that he has had on this
commission the contradiction that exists
between what was presented this
committee two years ago and what is
being proposed now thank you thank you
for the question um can I ask the
question of the representative real
quick go right ahead before I respond um
I guess that's this amendment here that
was previous of 2022 and that being said
could you point out where in this
document that page one line three I
apologize I'm sorry on the document in
front of you page one line three section
two where it reads ownership
transfer I mean it doesn't get any more
clearer than that ownership
transfer okay the
um okay couple couple three things
um a passing of time brings different
people to a table which is where we
are this table and this chair is not
bound by or are these Representatives
Bound by the opinion of a chair of the
department two years
ago it's been
clear on this committee for all the
years that I have been here whether I
sit in this chair to my right or I sit
out with the rest of the representatives
out
there that um it has been the position
of this committee that the town of
miramac many many years ago made a
proposal asked for work to be done work
was done uh town of marac then made a
statement that their debt should have
been paid uh which was not a agreed by
um this committee over the years with
the amount of Maintenance and so forth
the tolls were taking away from the ends
of this road and it has always been
clear to me as one person that this
section of road should no longer be paid
by the turnpike system and we're showing
that that uh I believe one of the
numbers we saw represent had brought for
forward and I believe it was
substantiated that was
$60,000 a year minimum maintenance and
that the uh last Paving of this road was
$1.6 Million which is probably $2
million uh from my brief understanding
of just speaking with the Department
here um I can see where our language
this
time um would have created confusion
that if if uh if this remains in which I
I certainly believe it will and if this
passes a house which I certainly believe
it will and it does pass and goes to the
governor that the word maintenance is
going to be a boomerang back and forth
maintenance is is maintenance some
potholes is maintenance the is
maintenance the
resurfacing um but whatever whatever
maintenance is it's a drain from the
turnpike system we have less money
coming coming in uh if something happens
and we go back to less people traveling
on that road less and less money to take
care of that road so for my
position um and I'm open I'm open
for um discussion on it turning that
road over to class
five um seems to make the most sense and
takes the road back to clearly stating
that this is a town road now if town of
meramac as it has been suggested is
going to abandon this road and I don't
know what they're going to do uh maybe
they'll make a Skywalk like they did in
Boston uh then that'll be the choice of
the town of marac but my my concern here
on this committee and chairing this
committee is we are bleeding dollars
whether it be the turnpike or our own
roads and so I I support that represent
mels yes this is just for uh members of
the committee that weren't here in 2022
the reason that this is worded this way
is the Pro
in the previous 10-year plan this
project that is named here was the
removal of some of the toll booths and
we this was specifically worded to tie
it in with this particular project this
particular project no longer exists
therefore if it's if it if we want to
pass it it needs new wording and that's
the reason for it I could be wrong on
whether it was the uh the toll booth or
what but it was it was definite part of
the 10-year plan and it was just an
addendum to include it as part of that
removal represent Jack represent Jack uh
thank you Mr chairman uh can we be clear
on who owns uh Continental Boulevard
currently and that's from the
intersection with old rout three all the
way down to penu square is that is that
Turnpike system land that it's on or is
that town
land it's it's my belief that that's
turnpike would own the right of way for
that and I would believe it's a a fee
right of way and not an easement but I
have not confirmed that so then follow
up so then it would be critical that we
transfer ownership to the town uh which
is not in the amendment that we have
here so that it it ceases to be Turnpike
landed becomes Town land so classify so
we have to both transfer ownership and
then reclassify the road as class five
is that is that what we need to do it's
my understanding that reclassifying the
road also
reclassifies the the underlying property
whether it be land or
easement and thank you um and just to to
clarify
uh the bill as proposed to be amended
which would take that to a class five
Road class five Road clearly states that
this is no longer a Turnpike Road and
that this is a Town Road that's correct
okay thank you rson Boyd I apologize for
the enthusiasm there did you want to
have further
discussion see now
um
all
right so um for for yeah so all right
let's let's straw poll it once again
um which would be line
10 uh to reclassify Continental
Boulevard uh
miramac uh to become a class five Road
the Department of Transportation she'll
not be responsible for maintenance
Continental Boulevard in the town of
marac if you're if you're in agreement
with that change uh signified by just
raising your hand to straw
pole if you are opposed to
that right one all right so uh we're
going to need is there anything else
anything else in here that the committee
or the department uh thinks warrants
change at this time so I can get the
drafting
done okay so with last
chance okay with that we are going to uh
adjourn from our 10 o'clock meeting and
we are scheduled to be back for 11 we're
going to see how hopefully we can wrap
this up here today I go speak with
legislative Services thank
you want
you want to take a walk for us
yep so we're we're g to try we're gonna
at 11 o'clock by 11 o'clock I'll have an
answer hopefully when
uh
um you have before you Amendment 0961 H
amendment to House Bill
2024 uh we had asked for a um a change
on line 10 page three which now reads
reclassification Continental Boulevard
miramac Continental boulard in the town
of marac is reclassified as a class five
highway it's the it's the change um that
was brought forward so um I will uh
recognize repon Mills to uh for a
motion uh thank you Mr chairman I move
uh Amendment 961 H to House Bill 2024 as
ought to pass I will second that motion
Mr chairman motion by Mill seconded by
cluder um Amendment
0961 ought to pass um is there
discussion on the
amendment seeing none uh if you're in
favor of the motion you'll signify by
saying I or yes nay or no if you
opposed
um the clerk will call the role thank
you Mr chair representative cluder
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative fidi yes we got to be a a
little bit louder today we're in a big
room okay representative new I'm sorry
representative
McDonald
yes representative
kazinski representative
Bowden representative
Boyd Boyd votes nay representative
Melvin yes representative bogert yes
representative Connor yes representative
Jack yes representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar
I representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton
yes representative Peterson yes
representative bone is excused
representative jurus yes chairman mccon
chairman votes I yes the motion passes
Mr chair
18-1 18 to1 thank you uh Mr clerk I
would like to uh I would now uh make a
motion to uh pass House Bill
2024 as
amended um and I representative cluder
okay I have a question just to be sure I
I think we're in agreement I just want
to be sure every member of of my caucus
is okay with this otherwise I'd ask for
a brief caucus are you all set with the
B this bill as amended I just want to be
sure I can if you have further questions
can always talk afterwards but if we're
all set unless anybody has questions or
concerns I will move right to the vote
because I know time uh we have probably
other things to do are are you a second
represent CL yeah I will second that
though just to be clear I'm seconding
but I anybody who has concerns I'm
willing to discuss them in a talk
us seeing none okay so I think we're all
set Mr chair on my side of the
aisle
um any uh before I call the rooll any
further
discussion seeing none if you're in
favor of the motion how House for um
House Bill 2024 is amended signified by
saying I or yes if you were opposed
it'll be nay or no with that Mr clerk
would you call the role thank you Mr
chair representative cluder uh yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative
foli
yes representative McDonald yes
representative
kazinski representative Bowden
representative Boyd Boyd votes n
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative
Connor representative Jack yes
representative Abbott
yes representative Edgar I
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton yes
representative Peterson yes
representative vone is excused
representative jurus yes chairman
mccon um
I motion passes Mr chair 18 to one thank
you um I want to thank the um the
committee for the time put into this
bill and your uh Indulgence patience and
um I'm proud of what we've what we put
together here um we will stand in um
recess um and thank you and I think
we'll uh we'll let Finance take their
room back over it just seems just a
little too big for me in here so and as
Vice chair on behalf of the committee
thank you very much Mr chairman I think
this has been a good process and I
appreciate your cooperation and working
together with everybody and we'll take
to sah house Flor and uh hopefully
will'll pass thank
you